ça c'est une nitrite de sodium
Cyril ça ça peut déboucher un cut non
plus que ça
avec ça
on tue 50 personnes
j'ai 200 g 200 g
eorges
c'est
quelqu'un qui qui a été pris dans cet
état là ne doit plus jamais avoir de
permis et puis ça va au-delà
effectivement
c'est ça sur lequel évidemment il faut
parler parce que le public parfois peut
nous reprocher de mettre les projecteurs
sur Pierre Palmade et d'oublier le drame
que vit cette famille aujourd'hui vous
avez vu qu'il n'a pas été mis en
détention provisoire et c'est la règle
c'est la loi qui dit ça c'est vraiment
il y a pas eu de
passe-droit
vous avez réagi comment cette on était
stupéfait il a fait un acte
qui devait se passer autrement ils
devaient être condamnés rapidement et
très rapidement en fait mais avec un
bracelet je pense qu'il pourra faire
autre chose
c'est simplement incroyable parce que
d'après tout ce qu'on nous a dit le
beau-frère devait prendre une autre
route et c'est parce que elle était
enceinte qu'il a voulu éviter les dos
d'âne et qu'il a malheureusement pris
cette route droite c'est est-ce que
c'est pas la signature que tout était
écrit
vos paroles peuvent choquer je pense ce
que vous dites là parce que il y a une
question de fatalité non il encourt une
peine très sévère bien sûr quelle peine
c'est théoriquement il encourt jusqu'à
10 ans
dans ce genre d'affaires ça peut se
traduire par une peine mixte de l'ordre
de 4,5 ans assorti en partie du sursis
avec de la mise à l'épreuve les
obligations de soins donc il faut pas
penser une seconde que parce qu'il a pas
été placé en détention ce soir il a eu
un régime de faveur ce n'était pas écrit
bah c'est-à-dire que la responsabilité
c'est pas Dieu c'est Pierre Palmade si
vous
de toute façon Dieu ou pas
sur pierre évidemment choqué ce qui nous
est comment pouvoir parce que si on
exclut toujours sa propre responsabilité
sur ce qu'on fait personne
jusqu'en 1924 c'était personne n'avait
de l'idée d'utiliser ça dans la
charcuterie 1924 il y a des crapules
américaines du de en fait de la mafia
dans l'Illinois
des des personnalités plus ou moins
corrompues de mettre du nitrite de
sodium dans la charcuterie la France a
dit tout le temps il en est pas question
c'est belle promesse que j'entends ce
n'est que du vent oh bravo
[Applaudissements]
voilà
ok moi je joue pas 1934 je vais pas
faire un cours d'histoire là mais c'est
ça que je raconte dans le bouquin
1934 Adolf Hitler arrive au pouvoir et
il autorise le nitrite de sodium dans la
charcuterie c'est le premier en Europe
qui autorise à officiellement
[Musique]
vous venez d'où vous êtes anglaise non
d'origine pas du tout c'est-à-dire
suédoise
à moins que Saint-Nazaire et déménagé en
Angleterre
de la prostate jusque là rien d'étonnant
il a été prise en charge mais il s'est
passé un syndrome un peu étrange alors
cet homme
âgé à peu près de la cinquantaine était
pris en charge par hormonothérapie alors
on savait que ce traitement pouvait
générer des effets indésirables comme
l'hypertension ou des infections
urinaires mais ce qui lui est arrivé
était un petit peu différent il s'est
mis à parler avec l'accent irlandais
c'est absolument de le syndrome de
l'action étranger
je suis aussi frappé par ce soir je suis
né en France et que suite à une
opération une petite opération bénigne
je me suis réveillée avec cet accent
avec l'accent anglais
sans rire
mais c'était une opération c'est un truc
qu'on peut dire ou pas c'était quoi
c'était la gorge les amis d'ânes un truc
comme ça
je parle pas comme vous d'après le
British médical journal en tout cas qui
rapporte ce cas donc aucune explication
averée alors les médecins ont juste
observé que le cancer continue à
progresser mais jusqu'ici pas possible
non plus de faire un lien ils émettent
l'hypothèse de mécanisme hormonaux
encore inconnu et du coup ils disent que
tout ça bah ça mérite davantage de
recherche pour mieux comprendre en 2015
le Centre international de recherche sur
le cancer le CERC c'est l'agence cancer
de l'OMS c'est les tops c'est des c'est
l'autorité mondiale sur le cancer a
classé un aliment un seul aliment en
cancérogène certains on a pas d'autres
les charcuteries s'il y en a pas
d'autres
la démence fronton temporale une maladie
peu connue pour laquelle il n'existe
aucun traitement proche d'Alzheimer elle
touche entre 50 et 60 000 personnes aux
États-Unis 15 à 20 000 en France la
plupart des patients ont entre 50 et 65
ans la maladie de Bruce Willis est
incurable en annonçant ainsi que
l'acteur souffre d'une forme de démence
ses proches espèrent sensibiliser le
public et faire avancer la recherche
music Félix
The Voice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]